Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is my
new spider-man no way home video sony and marvel
released a bunch of new promos we'll break it down
there's a bunch of easter eggs i know you have all
kinds of questions about what's going on with the
movie because we're getting closer and closer to
the end of the year thankfully we've gotten our
first look at spider-man and doctor strange in the
movie and we've gotten a bunch of new looks at his
suits and some of their abilities if you're new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and just careful for spoilers from the loki
series if you have not seen that yet because i'll
be talking a little bit about how that sets up
spiderman no way home during the video but you may
have seen a lot of the promos in your timeline the
past couple of weeks and some of these first looks
and scenes from the movie there's also a lot of
stray promos and tie-ins referencing plot points
like the whole mysterio cliffhanger scene as well
as some of spider-man's new suits and abilities
like the black and gold suit the integrated suit
with spider-man wielding magic like doctor strange
peter parker doesn't know anything about how to
use magic so it's not like he's going to become
a sorcerer during the movie or anything like that
i'll explain how he's able to use magic with the
new spider-man suits because it's a cool twist on
a concept that they explored in the comics a long
time ago more recently it'll also probably remind
you of the peter parker spider-man that we're
going to see during the what if episodes the
spider-man that wears the cape spider-man does not
wear a cape just everyone posts all the memes from
spider-man into the spider-verse he's a version
of spider-man who's wielding dr strange's cloak of
levitation he's an alternate universe version of
peter parker but his official designation on the
show at least as far as we know is zombie hunter
spider-man the producers of what if explained
what's going on with him during the show so we'll
talk about that at the end of the video i know
you're all wondering when we're going to get the
new spiderman no way home trailer as well so i'll
address that because of what's happened recently
with some of the announcements that sony has made
spider-man no way we're going to get that trailer
but starting with this new first look at spiderman
no way home the main mcu sacred timeline version
of spider-man as we call him now after the loki
series yes the events of the movie do overlap with
the events of the loki series a little but kang
himself king the conqueror in the other variants
of kang that they teased at the end of that won't
be huge villains during spider-man no way home
it's still a spider-man movie obviously there's
been all those rumors about the andrew garfield
spider-man and toby maguire spider-man characters
coming in there are a couple of those sinister six
characters that have been confirmed but there's
still a ton of rumors about other villains showing
up there's a multiverse element in play that i'll
talk about in a second but it's not completely
relevant to what's happening during this first
look here in this new scene though we're seeing
spider-man coming to talk to doctor strange
and if you couldn't tell just from the facade
of the buildings here or the style of the street
construction this is meant to be bleeker street
and he's come to the front door of the new york
sanctum zoom in enhance you can see doctor strange
is still wearing the eye of agamotto and his
costume from avengers end game just coming out to
meet him the reason why i think this is happening
earlier in the movie is one because both of them
have their older suits from the previous movies
like spider-man and his steve ditko red and black
suit from the end of spider-man far from home
they're just calling that the upgraded suit during
the movie because there are many suits during the
movie the only main doctor strange costume change
recently in the marvel movies was that he lost the
time stone during avengers infinity war to thanos
and then thanos atomized that version of the
infinity stones during endgame so we still got the
amulet but not the time stone yes scarlet witch
did use her chaos magic in the hex to recreate
an infinity stone when she recreated hex vision
and her chaos magic power is canonically similar
to the energy given off by the infinity stones
the background cosmic radiation that they
talked about on wand division but the whole
idea is that that version of the mind stone
that she recreated only worked inside the hex
the minute that hex vision stepped outside the
hex he just completely started to break down
so that's the way of class balancing her so to
speak like yes you can create infinity stones
but they only work inside this bubble here so
unless you made a hex to cover the entire planet
they wouldn't really be any good to you elizabeth
olsen said that the way they use her character
scarlet witch during doctor strange two will be
just a little bit different but for the most part
they're building on what they did with her in wand
division but because spider-man no way home is
primarily a spider-man movie with some doctor
strange in it there'll be some magic but they
really won't be digging deeper into the nature of
magic just in general in the mcu till you get to
doctor strange too the other really obvious easter
egg that you probably spotted in this spider-man
doctor strange scene here is the feast truck most
of you will remember feast from the spider-man ps4
game or the spider-man miles morales game feast
started in the comics it's an acronym that stands
for food emergency aid shelter and training
martin lee mr negative created in the comics to
be a humanitarian aid charity organization just to
help in times of crisis just generally help people
around the city secretly though his mr negative
persona was using the fee shelters as a front
for his criminal activity in his inner demons
gang and eventually in the comics after spider-man
stopped mr negative aunt may liked the idea and
just took them and used them as actual shelters
to help people but there are a number of ways
to explain why they have the fee shelters in the
movie i haven't heard anything about mr negative
being a character in the movie but i'm assuming
they'll be part of the larger sinister six plot
and there will be some easter eggs for the comic
book version of the fee shelters like someone
using them as a front for something really shady
also it's kind of shady that there's a feast truck
parked right outside the sanctum like one of the
greatest centers of power in new york city just
happens to be parked right outside no big deal
nothing special going on here and while this
is him outside the sanctum we've actually
already gotten a first look at spider-man ned
leads and mj inside the sanctum if you didn't
make the connection earlier this year when
they released these scenes from the movie
you see them entering this really run down looking
building like the scooby gang or something they're
actually entering the sanctum here this scene of
them standing in this really run down looking room
with the snow piling up against the interior walls
the paint peeling like everything's all run down
like everything's just decaying it's actually the
main entry room of the sanctum you can see the
floor pattern here is the exact same in the other
scenes you see spider-man and the other two trying
to solve a problem using ned lee's laptop notice
he's got the this is fine sticker from the meme
i think it's a nice wink to spider-man's
current predicament having been doxxed by
mysterio to the entire world like everything
is on fire but no worries everything is fine
if you saw the merchandise integrations they
depict some of the things that will be happening
with spider-man inside the sanctum it probably
won't be exactly like we see in all these toy
and merchandise integrations but you get the idea
and it shows you some of the new spider-man suits
wong also seems like one of the characters that
gets a huge costume upgrade we just saw him in the
shang chi trailer getting his ass kicked by the
abomination in that mortal kombat style tournament
my big theory as to why the sanctum looks so run
down in all these scenes is the doctor strange
does spiderman a solid and allows him to hide out
in the sanctum just because he has nowhere to go
like the title spiderman no way home is a metaphor
for his storyline in the movie is also referenced
to what's happening with the villains which gets
back to the plot of loki king in the multiverse
war but it sounds like doctor strange does him
a solid and just allows him to use the sanctum
to hide out there's a rumor right now that the
title no way home is a reference to the sinister
six villains being multiverse villains we know
they're from the multiverse but them having no
way home because of the events of the kang
multiverse war them literally not being able
to go back to where they're from because you have
kang variants all over the multiverse erasing
realities the whole thing with spider-man wielding
magic though with this black and gold suit in the
promo in this other iron spider looking suit
which they're calling the integrated suit
is i believe it's meant to be a reference
to doctor strange integrating his magic with
the suits you notice the magical shield that it
seems like he's using has spider-man symbols and
runes baked into it the whole concept of combining
different avengers abilities and suits with magic
goes way back to the old what if comics there
was a version of iron man that became sorcerer's
supreme and built a version of an iron man suit
programmed with all this spells so that he could
wield magic without having to cast spells saving
himself a bunch of time automatic spell casting
so i don't think that doctor strange is trying
to turn spider-man into a sorcerer or anything
they're not going full spider-man sorcerer supreme
he's just integrating a couple extra abilities and
powers into the suits that spider-man can use
the same way he uses all of his other abilities
that are built into the suits speaking of the
doctor strange version of spider-man talking
about that version that we saw in the what if
art with him wearing the cloak of levitation
as his name zombie hunter spider-man implies
it sounds like he's a big part of the marvel
zombies story line in the what if episodes which
seem like they boil over around the events of
avengers infinity war benedict cumberbatch is
doing the voice of doctor strange in the series
so the version of his doctor strange just from an
alternate universe that goes way darker you notice
he's wearing a very different looking cloak so it
sounds like spider-man was given the traditional
cloak of levitation as a power upgrade in this
because his version of doctor strange wasn't
using it or didn't need it it's also a funny way
to pay off this scene from avengers infinity war
where spider-man tries to have a conversation with
the cloak of levitation the whole thing with the
spider-man no way home trailer is that you may
have heard that venom let there be carnage was
delayed just a couple weeks to mid-october so i
think that sony is probably just waiting to make
sure that they don't have to delay spider-man no
way home before they start releasing trailers and
promos the best theory right now is they'll
wait till marvel actually releases shanxi
and the legend of the ten rings in theaters and
attached the spiderman no way home trailer to that
or they'll wait till venom let there be carnage
his theaters i don't think it has anything to do
with spoiling anything from the movie or any big
plot points with multiverse or toby maguire or
andrew garfield i think it's just about sony being
afraid of having to delay spiderman no way home i
will do more videos for the movie when we get more
information or they actually do start releasing
some footage my full marvel what if episode 2
video will post on wednesday just like normal
it's going to be the big black panther star-lord
episode it is going to be a banger so everyone
click here for my what if episode 2 trailer video
and click here for my full what if episode 1
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you in the next video!